[Music]
and never goes as planned muse submitted
by bass right bish
that's right bish Americans share common
disasters that happen on Thanksgiving
Day oh I like my fires from the turkey
or some family disasters so this new
survey of 2,000 Americans found that you
can expect about six things to go
completely wrong for your Thanksgiving
dinner
drunk in law's getting into a fight
that's entertaining the turkey barns so
then they were saying that um 56% so
more than half other people being
surveyed they did say that cooking the
turkey correctly is one of the hardest
parts about hosting a Thanksgiving
dinner
it's [ __ ] your heart it's [ __ ] hard
does dark meat and then there's white
meat and then they need different
temperatures and then you end up like
one part gets all juicy and other parts
yeah well other parts all dry is fun why
don't we turkey on Thanksgiving the
pilgrims ate it it oh is that fact it's
not facts right no I don't know I think
it was just a light turkey like that
it's like dry yeah like ham is better
I just get turkey because it feels
festive yeah yeah yeah like you're just
used to us here like let's just be it's
old-school marketing actually part of
what they say too that a big percentage
of the people they don't even really
like a lot of Thanksgiving dishes but
they'll eat it because it's just part of
tradition what Thanksgiving food is good
fried turkey and smoked turkey oh really
good well we had smoked turkey one year
was it good juicy juicy everywhere it
was yeah you could order a smoked turkey
from like one of those beef jerky houses
they're really good so another one says
31 percent of them claim not getting any
of the cooking done before dinner time
was the most common fail followed by
having to wait on a dish or two still
cooking before finally diving into the
food which was 29% and nearly 76% of
Americans surveyed agreed that
Thanksgiving would be much more
pleasurable
if cooking was erased from the process
so I can go to Marie Callender's and get
the Thanksgiving in a box T yeah we're
like what's the other one Boston Market
yeah or KFC I've had Thanksgivings from
both of those places mm-hmm Marie
Callender's what is that what you said
yeah you go there and there's the pie
that cranberry the stuffing all that
stuff more efficient all's in in Japan
everyone gets KFC for Christmas yeah
that's like their thing right yeah I
don't know why I don't know where that
holiday like think yeah but it's like
everyone gets KFC for Christmas looks
like a turkey
Christmas with ham right maybe there's a
red box with a lawless town oh maybe
maybe Colonel Sanders look like Santa
Claus wow he does that's funny and it's
red there was this other study where it
also surveyed 2000 Americans and they
came up with the most hated and
celebrated Thanksgiving dishes so the
most hated Thanksgiving dish do you guys
want to get oh not stuffed turkey bring
the turkey pumpkin pie I love I love
pumpkin pie too but I know people that
hate it I had to learn to like that
Oh green beans green bean casserole
Grammy Oh actually my favorite is the
most-hated which is canned crab canned
cranberry sauce okay you don't like
canned cranberry sauce no I just can't
yours like put it there right it's just
a sweet jelly and you like to place it
you addict with your turkey breast yeah
or your cornbread they're saying that
46% of those polled called the canned
version disgusting also specifically
cans and canned cranberry sauce which is
my specific favorite I don't like a
homemade like cranberry sauce no it
needs to be in the can in the shape of
the can oh [ __ ] like a shape of dog fur
uh Thanksgiving was it like Mexican
Thanksgiving yeah like it's like Mexican
dish and Thanksgiving stuff like well
yeah well
not for me for me like I said I have KFC
we do that for Philippine that you know
side it's like Poinsett lumpia adobo
chicken and then all the way to sit up
that's the beach and stuff
no there was like all the after the fact
but like growing up my entire life I'm
not saying your upbringing but like now
like when I go now I'll see like ceviche
I'll see like up was all day with Turkey
yeah yeah boy I feel like my mom just
used to buy the turkey cuz it's like
what we were supposed to buy you know
but in reality I remember one year like
she like [ __ ] up the turkey and we
made and she loves and that was cool you
know yeah do you make tamales during
Christmas my mom my mom makes them but
sometimes she'd just buy some because
it's a lot of work yeah like a lot of
our families now here a lot of them are
in Mexico so it's just us a lot of times
so yeah she doesn't really go all out
cuz it's a lot of work
I made them one year it was a bomb but
yeah was a lot of work yeah and it's
like an all-day process like should be
like all you guys had to come help me on
Sunday not really have I don't like it I
like putting the masa on the corn husk
and all that I made it Christmas dinner
tamales in a steam all holidays right
yeah yeah we do it in the winter like I
mean people you know year-round yeah and
you put them in the freezer and [ __ ]
what's on it - I like pozole is my
noodle a weekend dish or is there a
holiday tied to it - well some people
really like it but I like the legit
hangover type of I like Portola for that
but I think because Manila is like the
tongue and like the meat is like I'll
slimy I'm learning all this stuff and
then it's just so white I don't like it
like literally white like it's clear and
see - right yes like that honeycomb
tripe thing working yeah yeah I like
this one better I could see what's there
I don't even eat the lining or anything
I end up just drinking this soup I got
put a whole bunch of lime and oh I just
drink the soup that's alright anyway so
back to this they're saying that
uh the iconic pumpkin pie which is
another one my favorite een people hate
it I don't know why it's so [ __ ] good
Steve hates it eats pumpkin pie wait no
eyes this favor no wait carrot cakes
affair no yes I mixed up with his
favorite is he yeah he hates pumpkin pie
this taste buds are fried from all the
monsters I don't even know what I'm
really like loves carrot cake carrot
cake is his favorite cake ever
I just got over carrot cake me too
especially with eyes hands on route
Costco pumpkin pie yeah pumpkin the
whole thing by myself just like a little
bit right no it was pretty badass scary
cuz like you could just keep eating it I
know next thing you know you're like
[ __ ] I've even three slices of meat you
know don't ever buy raps well goodbye
the lowest is gross it's like it's just
it's not and then they actually like
filling of it doesn't even have a lot of
pumpkin flavor it's just bland Italy
like canned flavor and then it leaves
that film on the roof of your mouth
kinda [ __ ] where it's like so artificial
yeah go to Costco yeah I like all
pumpkin pies hmm and yams yeah my
pumpkin pie or a pumpkin cheesecake yeah
from Costco yeah from pasta I caused it
to yeah oh [ __ ] I need to try it
hmm yeah so 21% of participants said
that they secretly hates pie in general
I do secretly hate it admit it
yeah because it's really baked it I put
a long time and they don't want to share
that they're stupid they don't wanna
reveal that so then they're saying that
19 percent of those polled
didn't find pumpkin pie or sorry the
entire holiday all that even necessary
oh well they just don't like joy they
don't like family they don't like
togetherness but then it's always like
in the movies two people hate doing the
Thanksgiving thing because they get
together and they fight with their
family
cuz like my thinks givings are never
like that
yeah they're chill yeah we just get
together we eat and we don't Scrabble
and yeah one of those holidays for you
where you're like like if you didn't get
to celebrate is that year you you really
feel like you missed out on a holiday I
feel like I missed that in the eating
I'm like I'm cool like I feel like
people made him more into like oh the
day where I eat everything you know
where it's like this boy yeah yeah
extreme cheat day - yeah maybe that's
where I got it from but yeah I mean I
just like it because I'm like ooh am I
gonna eat all day and also I don't eat
why people food every day oh I don't
know when I eat Thanksgiving food I feel
like this is true [ __ ] it's like you're
getting a cultural food yeah it's
different it's one day you get to be
white the whole year mashed potato and
sushi you know that's all good oh it's
like it's it's super mixed but like
maybe because the survey people are
white so like they eat this stuff
normally yeah they eat turkey I don't
know what part of America they got
mashed potatoes and all that stuff like
on a regular so maybe for them it's like
cracker get [ __ ] stuffing meatloaf
whatever you talked about was like
people food that is huh yeah and
McDonald yeah that's some stoner people
food true real America right there yeah
talk about yes then the people so this
is everything that they hated right now
we're gonna talk about what they
actually want to eat on Thanksgiving in
84 percent said that they eat pie on
Thanksgiving with pumpkin being the
favorite at 31 percent and then apple
and pecan tying for second at 18 percent
hosted the COS pretty good and then they
also said that 75 percent said that they
drink wine on the holiday with red as
the favorites but that's just a normal
day okay so it's PI an album alone
that's exactly what they want is longer
than wine that's it dude that sounds
like such a little attitude just to get
together let's all hop I am wine all
feast like kings [ __ ] the turkey yeah
it's all jars yeah it's like you feel
like you have to earn the dessert and
wine by eating the turkey
thing are these cuz most people don't
know how to do the turkey right I
definitely got no hana by church you
order a place that already smokes a
turkey and does it right you just got to
warm it up that shit's [ __ ] bowling
sake period it's like that yeah there's
another meat since I gave up yeah meat
basically like and there's not really
fish at Thanksgiving
it's just a lot of carbs so like I eat
like mashed potatoes and Penn said that
sounds good doing like mashed potatoes
well I'm getting hungry now and now I'm
gonna go to Boston Market
[Music]